>> Tucker: NASA ANNOUNCED IT
HAS DISCOVERED ORGANIC MATERIAL
THE BUILDING BLOCKS OF LIFE ALL
THE WAY ON MARS BUT THAT'S NOT
THE ONLY FASCINATING SPACE
RELATED NEWS TO COME OUT
RECENTLY.
ACCORDING TO A NEWLY LEAKED
PENTAGON REPORT, AND 2004 A U.S.
AIRCRAFT CARRIER WAS STOCKED FOR
SEVERAL DAYS BY A UFO BY
WITNESSES WHO SAID IT RESEMBLED
EIGHT SUPERSONIC TIC TAC, IT
COULD MAKE ITSELF INVISIBLE.
THIS SHOCKED AND CONFUSED NAVY
PILOTS WHO MONITORED IT.
NEXT, WHY WOULD INFORMATION ON
THIS -- WHY WOULD WE NEED TO
READ ABOUT IT BECAUSE IT WAS
LEAKED?
WHY ONE TO THE U.S. TELL US
THIS, IS THERE SOME REASON?
>> I THINK THERE'S ALWAYS
EMBARRASSMENT ON ANYTHING IN OUR
AIRSPACE THE PERFORMANCE FACTORS
SIX EXCEED IN OUR INVENTORY.
IF THAT WAS THE CONCLUSION IN
THIS PENTAGON DOCUMENT, THIS
THING RAN RINGS AROUND OUR F-18
SUPER HORNETS THAT TRIED TO
CHASE THIS THING, IT WAS BRIEFLY
TRACKED ON RADAR BUT IT SEEMS TO
BE ABLE TO -- AGAIN IT'S A
PHRASE FROM THE DOCUMENT IT'S
ALMOST LIKE IT CLOAKED ITSELF
AND BECAME INVISIBLE.
YOU'D THINK THIS WAS A SCIENCE
FICTION IF YOU WEREN'T READING
IT IN PENTAGON DOCUMENTS AND WE
KNOW NOW THAT THE GOVERNMENT
TOOK THIS VERY SERIOUSLY, THESE
THINGS ARE BE SEEING IN OUR
SKIES BY PILOTS TRACKED ON RADAR
AND IT'S A SERIOUS DEFENSE OF
NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE HERE.
>> Tucker: WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT ANY OTHER COUNTRY POSSESSES
THE TECHNOLOGY TO CREATE AN
AIRCRAFT LIKE THIS.
>> ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WENT INTO
THIS REPORT WAS LOOKING TO SEE
IF THIS SORT OF THING WAS ANY
THING IN OUR OWN INVENTORY AND
INDEED ANYTHING THAT ANY OTHER
NATION HAS.
WHEN I WAS INVESTIGATING UFOs
FOR THE BRITISH GOVERNMENT, WE
KNEW THAT SOME OF THESE THINGS
WOULD TURN OUT TO BE SECRET
PROTOTYPE AIRCRAFT DRONES AND
MISSILES.
WE ALWAYS KNEW WHO HAS WHAT SO
YOU CAN ELIMINATE THAT.
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU ARE REALLY
SAYING IS THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
AND THE BRITISH GOVERNMENT HAS
ESSENTIALLY CONCLUDED IT'S
SOMETHING NOT FROM THIS WORLD
THAT IS BEEN CHECKED ON RADAR
AND WATCHED BY PEOPLE WHO WATCH
AIRCRAFT FOR LIVING -- THIS IS
REAL.
>> IT IS REAL.
THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T GO SO FAR
AS TO SAY THESE THINGS ARE
EXTRATERRESTRIAL BUT CERTAINLY
WHEN I WAS DOING THIS FOR THE
MINISTRY OF DEFENSE OUR POLICY
STATEMENT SAID NEITHER DO WE
RULE OUT THAT POSSIBILITY.
WE KEPT AN OPEN MIND ON THIS.
THEIR SPEEDS AND MANEUVERS ARE
IN EXCESS OF ANYTHING THAT
YOU'VE GOT, YOU ARE FORCED
ALMOST TO THINK THE UNTHINKABLE.
PART OF THE PROBLEM WAS THAT
SENIOR POLITICAL FIGURES AND
MILITARY CHIEFS OFTEN JUST SAID
UFOs AND THEY ROLLED THEIR
EYES AND IT WAS THE RIDICULE
FACTOR.
>> Tucker: WE ARE OUT OF TIME